(upbeat holiday music)
- My name is Ada (indistinct),
and I'm seven and a half,
and I live in Charlotte, North Carolina.
And what I want from Christmas
from Santa is another dog.
As you can see, I have one right here,
and his name is Pizza, and
I think he deserves a wife.
So I'm gonna name that dog Hot Dog.
Bye.
(applauding)
- Notice that Pizza got up
when a wife was mentioned.
I'm just saying.
I am here with Poppy Montgomery
and Linda Cardellini.
(drowned out by cheering)
All week we have teamed up
with our season-long
partner Pilot Frixion Pen,
the go-to erasable pen of
the Kelly Clarkson Show,
to give Santa an assist with
some Christmas wishlists.
Try and say that five times fast.
It'd be different than Jack Kaufman.
(laughing)
Nice callback.
That was seven-year-old Ada who wants
to find a wife for her dog Pizza.
Pizza seemed excited about it.
Ada, we want to celebrate
kids like you who create fun
and ambitious gift lists so fearlessly.
And we think pizza also
deserves a wife, as well.
So we're giving you a thousand dollars
to help you get a second
dog and take care of her.
Merry Christmas and sorry, parents,
if you didn't want that
to happen (laughs).
And everyone watching,
remember you can pick up
Pilot Frixion Erasable Pens
wherever office supplies are sold.
They're rad, you'll want 'em, trust me.